hay conmoción entre muchos alemanes tras
el tiroteo del jueves en la noche en
Hamburgo en especial Porque son poco
comunes los tiroteos en Alemania en
comparación con otros países las
autoridades explicaron este viernes en
una rueda de prensa que según la
información que han podido recabar el
presunto atacante no tenía una
motivación política ni el tiroteo un
trasfondo terrorista si bien es cierto
que las investigaciones continúan más
bien todo parece indicar que las
investigaciones están centrando en un
posible problema de Salud Mental del
atacante o en problemas personales del
atacante con la comunidad de los
Testigos de Jehová a la que había
pertenecido antes de salir de ella de
mala manera las autoridades también
explicaron este viernes que el presunto
atacante había obtenido su arma de
manera legal lo que está generando todo
tipo de preguntas en Alemania sobre cómo
es posible que haya podido obtener un
arma teniendo en cuenta por un lado que
Alemania considerado uno de los países
con las leyes deporte de armas más
estrictas y por el otro lado sabiendo
que como dijeron las propias autoridades
habían recibido una información anónima
antes del ataque advirtiendo de un
posible problema de Salud Mental del
atacante así las cosas Las
investigaciones continúan y también
continúa y probablemente crecerá el
debate político en Alemania tras el
ataque tras el tiroteo del jueves en la
noche en Hamburgo